you were like uh you were kind of like I
feel like
we were just talking a bit off the
camera but you were kind of like the
veteran that I felt like the Young Dudes
really also respected on your team so
would that be yeah you know I just I led
by example you know what I mean like I
played my ass off I'll do anything for
the team they know I'm team first and
and I treated them like my family so
whenever there was Smoke on the court
they knew I was gonna be in it like all
the majority of the times I got fined
like I find like I lost probably oh uh
they said something over like half a
million dollars in fines Jesus
um it was never me starting something
was me coming to the defense of a
teammate the only person that paid my
files that man was cold but everyone
else let me take them shits that was
[ __ ] up because you defend somebody so
yeah man I mean like I said I mean
that's just like I said I I grew up with
you know a father that if your brother
and sister fight fight you better fight
man if they win or lose you better fight
it you're gonna get your ass with that
so oh you're gonna get your ass whooped
so that's kind of how I grew up so I
just always looked at my teammates's
family it was just like whenever it was
not that I'm the toughest baddest
[ __ ] but I'm always gonna just
know I'm always gonna have your back
right right or wrong I'm gonna have your
back so that's just kind of the the way
I played so you know when I spoke I was
never the star I was a role player but I
was never the star whatever but you were
starting a lot of your career man but
every team I was on you know like I was
a respected voice like I wouldn't say
too much you know I pick and choose when
I spoke but I was a respected voice
beginning because I think that I just
led by example yeah it's great so when
you had Kobe's back and you gotta fined
he paid your fines you're the only dude
that's crazy